in algorithmic heavy-tailed statistics
yeah thanks
um thanks for having me james um and the
other organizers so
uh this is the first half of the talk is
going to be sort of
survey-ish and the second half will be
based on this recent joint paper with
yeshwanth chair upon him jerry tarun
kathuria prasad raghavendra and niles
tripuranneni
for those of you who were in my talk in
the
previous workshop in this semester this
is based on the same paper but i'm going
to emphasize an almost
disjoint subset of ideas so if you like
these things it might still be worth
sticking around
uh so the name of the game is going
to be doing
basic estimation problems in high
dimensions with sharp confidence
intervals
so we're going to be intriguing
statistics problems so given some
independent samples
from some high dimensional probability
distribution p
theta indexed by some parameters theta
the goal will be to estimate those
parameters by some estimator theta hat
such that theta hat is close to theta in
some norm
and close means in some quantitative
non-asymptotic sense like measured by
some rate
some error rate which we'll think of as
depending usually on the number of
samples you got
the ambient dimension of those samples d
and the probability with which i'm
willing to fail so i want this
inequality this error bound to hold with
probability
1 minus delta so this is measuring the
size of 1 minus delta confidence
intervals
for your estimator theta hat but since
this is
a concentration of measure workshop i
should say that an alternative way to
read
this statement is that the function
theta hat
of x1 through xn is concentrated
around data
we want this to work for some for p
theta in some class of probability
distributions p
and in studying heavy tailed statistics
what we're really doing is asking for
estimators theta hat which work for a
large class of distributions p
so uh today i will usually be interested
in the class of all distributions with
a constant number of uh bounded or
finite moments
um by contrast often when people study
confidence intervals for
classical estimators like empirical mean
empirical covariance
ordinary least squares regression they
often study them in the setting that the
underlying class of distributions is
gaussian so as you can imagine
if you get gaussian samples those
samples are well concentrated
and so it's not so surprising that some
function of those samples would be well
concentrated and that you would be able
to prove
inequalities like this the game we're
going to be we're going to play is to
try to prove similar inequalities
ideally matching the error rates that we
would have had if we had gaussian
samples
but with this much larger class of
distribution so the underlying
the underlying random variables will not
be well concentrated
and the estimators that we design will
have to do something non-trivial
by themselves biased
concentration
so that's kind of abstract let me
illustrate this with
an example which is s i think many of
you on this call have probably heard me
talk about this before but just
as a as a refresher so uh
the setup is that we get and samples
which
are independent copies of some
d-dimensional random vector
x let's say for sake of normalization
that the covariance of this random
vector is
identity and
if the random vector is gaussian then of
course we're just going to use the
empirical mean
to estimate the mean of this random
vector x
1 over n times the sum of the samples
and
if you use standard gaussian
concentration you can show that with
probability 1 minus delta the distance
between the empirical mean
and the population mean is this quantity
square root of d
over n plus square root of log one over
delta over n
and just to emphasize why this comes
from a simple concentration argument
um you can easily show that this term is
the expected distance
between the empirical mean and the
population mean
and this second term comes from a
gaussian type tail bound on
on the euclidean distance
so the abstract question i phrased on
the previous slide can be phrased here
more concretely is the question
can you drop the gaussian assumption and
retain
the same inequality well obviously you
can't retain that inequality if you are
going to still use the empirical mean
because if all i know about x1 to xn
is that they come from a distribution
with bounded covariance
the empirical mean will not be well
concentrated i won't get this kind of
gaussian concentration term
but maybe i can do it with some other
estimator so the first question you
might ask
ignoring this subscript here would be is
there some estimator mu hat
here i'm using mu because i'm talking
about the mean is there some estimator
mu hat that's a function of the samples
which is just as well concentrated
around the population mean
as the empirical mean was in the
gaussian case
the answer to that turns out to be no
for information theoretic reasons
but if you make a small weakening of
this of your
of your request to make it the answer
turns out to actually be yes quite
remarkably
so if you allow your estimator to depend
on the desired level of confidence delta
then you can actually show that there is
a
family of estimators one for each delta
such
that mu hat delta has the correct
distance to mu
with probability 1 minus delta
what this says is that you you don't
have to make gaussian assumptions in
order to get
tight confidence intervals in estimating
the mean in l2
so i'm gonna
just expand this very briefly
and then zoom back out so
in the ethics for a long time many of
you have probably seen these tricks that
gets you
uh sub-gaussian estimators of the mean
in uh
even when you only have distributions
with uh with a constant number of
moments these are tricks like median of
means
or now it's known that you can do this
by a truncated mean you take your
samples
these are now one dimensional and you
just throw out the tails and then you
take the empirical average
but it took quite a while for these
techniques to be generalized to high
dimensions it was not until
just a couple of years ago that lugosi
and mendelssohn designed this first
estimator that obtains this kind of
sub-gaussian tail guarantee or it's not
really a tail guarantee because of the
dependence on delta but subgaussian
confidence intervals
their estimator is based on some notion
of quantiles in high dimensions
again a high dimensional generalization
of this technique called median of means
which i'll get to in a little bit
but because their estimator has this
kind of combinatorial flavor to it
because it involves quantiles in high
dimensions
it looks like it's dangerously close to
things that we that we know are
computationally intractable and to
compute in high dimensions like tukey
median
so as far as anybody knows their
estimator requires exponential time to
compute exactly
and it wasn't until a little bit later
that there actually turned out to be an
algorithmic approach to computing
something like their estimator which
maintained the same guarantees
so a lot of this talk will be about this
uh general a general algorithmic
approach to dealing with quantiles
in in high dimensions
so the the sum of all of these things is
this theorem which is not the main
theorem capturing and algorithmic
heavy-tailed statistics
um for every sufficiently large delta
and delta can be quite tiny two to the
minus number of samples
there exists some estimator mu hat delta
which depends only on the samples
which has the sub gaussian confidence
interval guarantee
so it has the root d over n and then the
what the term that looks like it comes
from a gaussian tail bound
with probability one minus delta and you
can compute mu hat from the samples
in polynomial time uh
so this is what i mean by some resultant
algorithmic heavy-tailed statistics
if there are questions by the way i'm
monitoring the chat box if people want
to type
and otherwise i will make little pauses
but
now would be a reasonable time
the first one where you said exponential
time so that was
which ones um
so uh this this i mean i didn't tell you
what the estimator
is but but lugosi and mendelsohn
designed some
some kind of high dimensional median or
median isn't really the right term you
could think of it as some
uh some way to define high dimensional
quantiles and
they they said output a point which
which is nice with respect to high
dimensional quantiles
so i'll tell you later what what this
estimator is but their thing seems to
require exponential time to compute
sorry i think what i meant to ask was
exponential in
what oh good sorry
uh at least exponential
in let's say an either n or d there
might be algorithm
you might get min of nd i'm not exactly
sure i haven't thought about it so
carefully
um although actually uh okay actually i
take that back that was what that was
the algorithm that they
gave we now know how to compute their
estimator exactly
if you want in time
poly and d1 over delta if you want so
you can you can uh
you can be exponential in any one of the
three
i guess and actually actually uh
uh but it because of this relation this
algorithm is always better than a two to
the n time algorithm
but okay there's a question in the chat
is there a lower bound on delta for the
estimators of lugosi and mendelson
in their paper they did not write such a
lower bound but actually i think you do
need it i don't see how to make the
construction work if you have um
if you have a smaller delta than this
yeah good question
okay so the agenda for the rest of the
talk i'm gonna zoom back
out from mean estimation in l2 and spend
just do a little three slide survey of
what's going on
in this area because actually it's it's
fairly active
and then i'm going to describe this
recent results joint with
all these folks at berkeley on
heavy-tailed covariance estimation as
opposed to mean estimation
as i already discussed you know
getting sharp confidence intervals in
the heavy-tailed setting is is tied up
with concentration we're trying to
design
uh estimators which are well
concentrated about the thing that they
want to estimate
and in order to do that of course we're
going to have to employ
techniques from concentration of measure
to analyze to analyze them
so i think there are kind of two novel
applications of
ideas from concentration of measure that
i want to try to get to to describe
what we did in this covariance
estimation algorithm the first
is the first is a new way
to use the bounded differences in
equality just the classical bounded
difference in equality to analyze the
optima
of convex programs or analyze
concentration for the optima of convex
programs
and the second is a generalization of
the
matrix-bernstein inequality that we are
calling the
sum of squares bernstein inequality and
for some of you on the talk the
reference sum of squares will make sense
otherwise it hopefully will make sense
later in the talk
but just to give you i want to give you
a really brief preview of what this what
this is
just to um you know get you excited for
the
45th minute of the talk uh which is that
you know the matrix bernstein inequality
which probably many of you are familiar
with
it allows it's an extremely useful tool
it allows you to control
the operator norm of a sum of
independent
random matrices that looks like this
you can write the operator norm in a
variational way
you can write it as a semi-definite
program it's the maximum
over psd matrices of trace 1
of the inner product of y with the sum
of independent random matrices but it's
very useful
in our settings to be able to control
this kind of optimum value
for sums of independent random random
matrices when you look at the inner
product not just with this very simple
set of pst matrices but when you look at
something with many more linear
constraints so some some more
interesting set of psd matrices than
just the ones
of um of trace one so
we're able to prove uh a generalization
of matrix bernstein
which lets us control
a different norm of a sum of independent
matrices
these things called sum of squares norms
which we'll get to hopefully
which controls the max over y in some
more complicated semi-def family of
semi-definite programs some some very
useful family algorithmically
of these okay so that's a
that's a sneak preview of the kind of
kind of tools we're going to use uh so
now i want to i want to do a little bit
of uh
survey stuff just because i think
there's a number of cool things going on
so first of all i'm going to talk about
non-algorithmic things so
high-dimensional heavy-tailed statistics
but
where we don't yet worry about what can
be done in polynomial time
and here there's actually been you know
a cottage industry as you can see from
the
extensive list of list of references
a cottage industry in taking
um you know basic statistics problems
where we understood the optimal
confidence intervals
in the gaussian setting and designing
new more robust estimators
which maintain those guarantees with
only
a constant number of bounded moments so
dropping gaussian assumptions
we know how to do this now for mean
estimation in l2 as i described earlier
we know how to do it actually for mean
estimation in general norms
we know how to do it for covariance
estimation we know how to do it for a
wide range of regression problems
certainly including linear regression
but actually lots of
regression with much more general
function classes we know how to do it
for
say sparse recovery which is just one
example of a regularized regression
problem so we know
analogs of the lasso uh and i'm sure you
know i'm sure there are more i'm
actually not the world
not not such an expert on all of this
literature
um but by this point the theme should be
clear
for lots of statistics problems you can
drop gaussian assumptions and maintain
sharp confidence intervals
what if you want to do things in
polynomial time so
here everything is much murkier and
and much less thoroughly explored so by
now
we started with this mean estimation in
l2 problem and
for this the state of the art is an
algorithm
or a couple of algorithms due to two
different groups and the best running
time we know
is uh roughly quadratic time that's
by comparison to the first algorithm
which is the one i described
very briefly a couple of slides ago
which had polynomial but horrendously
large running time
as far as i know the only other problems
in this area which were investigated so
far from an algorithmic standpoint
are covariance estimation in operator
norm
in spectral norm and um and linear
regression
and in both cases not only in both cases
we do not know polynomial time
algorithms
which achieve optimal confidence
intervals and there seem to be
significant
roadblocks to obtaining them even though
we do know exponential time
estimators so for instance
in the case of covariance estimation uh
the first thing i'm aware of in this
area is an algorithm due to
minsker which
gives you confidence intervals that are
sub-optimal by some polynomial factor in
log one over delta now by contrast in
the in the mean estimation case
up to constant factors you get the right
confidence interval width
in this in this talk i'm going to
describe an algorithm which does a bit
better
our confidence intervals are still
sub-optimal but now by a log one over
delta to the one-quarter factor
and even though this seems like surely
we should have just worked a bit harder
and gotten the right answer
there are some good reasons to believe
this might actually be the best you
could do that's something i described in
a talk a couple of weeks ago
at the last workshop which you can find
online or ask me about a few
if you want but so i'm going to try to
get to get to
to this result um today in this talk
uh before i do last last survey-ish
thing
is i i already used once the word
robustness
so you know why are these problems
difficult well when you get samples from
a heavy-tailed distribution
many of them will be outliers right they
will they will lie far away
from from from the typical sample
and so any estimator that is going to
have good confidence intervals is
somehow going to have to be robust to
those kinds of outliers
and that suggests a connection to this
other very active area
of algorithmic high dimensional
statistics research
which is robust high dimensional
statistics
here robust has a technical meaning it
refers to
this huber contamination model where
you try to do statistics given instead
of being given independent samples
what happens is some samples are drawn
from some probability distribution
then they're handed to some malicious
adversary
who gets to modify in any way she
chooses
any epsilon fraction of those samples
and then gives you some new samples say
y 1 to y n and you need to do statistics
with those samples
um i can't say all that much about what
the connection actually is because it
seems like a sort of only in the last
six months or so have people started to
investigate this formally
it's clear that both areas are using
related techniques
both areas are using new notions of high
dimensional quantiles and new
algorithmic approaches to compute them
we also have seen a few a few works that
are
designing algorithms that simultaneously
are robust to
this kind of malicious outlier and
achieve
sharp confidence intervals but this this
seems this seems like a new and kind of
interesting direction to understand
what are the formal guarant
relationships between the heavy tailed
setting where we still have independent
samples but they might come from a nasty
distribution
and the robust setting where there is
some malicious tampering but just with a
small fraction of the samples
all right i'm going to move on
to this result on covariance estimation
unless there are
any other questions
and i'm going to pour myself some water
so you can all think
okay so
next up i want to talk about
heavy-tailed covariance estimation
um here is sorry it's a bit of a busy
slide but we'll
go through slowly so the setup as before
is you get some independent samples from
which are copies of some random vector x
in d dimensions
its covariance i'm going to call always
sigma
and just so that i can write down bounds
in simpler
simple looking forms i'm going to always
assume that sigma
is sort of like the identity matrix in
the sense that its trace
is about the ambient dimension d and its
maximum eigenvalue is about uh
of one our theorems actually don't
require this they
if you state them correctly they depend
in the right way on the trace and the
operator norm but
this is to save on notation
so our main theorem is the following um
you can find and in this setting you can
find an estimator
sigma hat sub delta or there's a family
of estimators sigma hat sub delta
such that the distance in operator norm
between sigma hat delta
and sigma is up to logarithmic factors
root d over n times log one over delta
to the one quarter
plus root log one over delta over n this
inequality holds with probability one
minus delta over the samples x one
through x
n and you can do it in polynomial time
under
this assumption which i will explain in
just a moment this assumption is called
certifiable to a type of contractivity
so we'll get there in the next slide
but before i explain the assumption on x
uh
let me make a couple other notes about
this
guarantee so as i said already um
in the radius of confidence intervals
that we obtain
uh are sub-optimal by
this log one over delta to the
one-quarter factor
they're also suboptimal by some hidden
logarithms here
we know how to remove that log one over
delta uh to the one quarter but
with some significant cost and running
time we have to pay time
that is polynomial in one over delta
instead of polynomial in
log one over delta
but for comparison the best previous
result due to minsker
actually has a root log one over delta
here so it's off by a larger polynomial
factor
although strictly speaking it's
incomparable it requires just a slightly
weaker
assumption
so let me describe before moving on to
talk about what the algorithm is i owe
you an explanation
of this assumption that i have put on
the underlying random vector
x so what is um
certifiable hyper contractivity well
let's start with hyper contractivity
hyper contractivity in this case two
eight hyper contractivity
in in our setting is just an assumption
of moment boundedness
on the uh on the eighth
moments of the underlying distribution x
so this is this is a kind of an
uh assumption that you should probably
be used to we this is this assumes that
the in any direction v so any uh any
vector v and d dimensions
the eighth moment of the one-dimensional
projection of this distribution
on the direction v is uh you know
only a constant factor bigger than the
fourth power of the second moment
and okay really i should put centered
moments here but for covariance
estimation you can always assume that
your distribution is um
is centered so we'll just work with the
raw moments and you can just implicitly
think of x as being centered here
so you know in order to estimate the
covariance which is a degree 2
polynomial in x we are degree two moment
in x
we we you know and should anticipate
having to make some kind of higher
moment assumption on x to get some any
high probability bounds
um the the best kind of thing that we
know in exponential time would make only
a 2-4 hyper-contractivity assumption we
need a 2-8 assumption
but we're still sort of being faithful
here to the notion that you would make
assumptions just on a constant number of
moments rather than assuming anything
like gaussian-ness
so that's 2a type of contractivity but
we're actually making a stronger
assumption than that we're making this
certifiability assumption the
certifiability is going to look a little
bit weird to you unless you're working
in algorithmic high dimensional
statistics the certifiability assumption
though
is is the following and we'll get a
little later to why this makes any sense
the assumption is that if you take the
difference between
the left and right hand sides of
this inequality so that's what's written
here that that difference
well we know it needs to be non-negative
for every v
the assumption is that not only is it
non-negative for every v
but that there is a simple witness to
this fact this witness should have the
form
of a set of polynomials in v so v
is some list of d variables you know
representing a vector
in d dimensions this witness should have
the form
some family of polynomials p i such that
the sum of the squares of those
polynomials is the difference between
left and right hand sides of the
inequality
so this is called the sum of squares
proof of this inequality
we'll get we'll get to that a little
later but for now
i should note that lots of distributions
of interest satisfy the certifiable
hyper-contractivity assumption and it's
become
by now a pretty standard assumption in
high dimensional
um algorithmic statistics often because
when when you when the a when the higher
moments of a distribution
are bounded but there's no simple
certificate for that fact
it's hard to see how to algorithmically
exploit those kind of
bounds on on higher moments so lots of
distribution satisfy this
um certainly product distributions of of
uh products of distributions with
bounded eighth moments will satisfy this
any mixtures of those of the above will
satisfy them
and the affine transformation uh
preserves this property and
you know lots of other lots of other
distributions so
uh ideally you would not like to have
this assumption here but we don't know
how to get off the ground without these
things and that's true in a lot of
robust statistics
high dimensional clustering and more
okay are there questions about the
theorem statement
all right
so to design our algorithm
the algorithm follows this high
dimensional median of means paradigm
median of means was pioneered by um
a number of folks and the references are
falling out of my head but a number of
folks in the
80s actually in one dimension the high
dimensional meaning of means paradigm
was pioneered by lugosi and mendelssohn
in the last few years
the paradigm is basically the following
a high dimensional median of means
estimator has two steps
first you take all of your samples and
blindly
you put them somehow into buckets uh the
number of buckets
we will always choose to be log one over
delta where delta is our desired
confidence
because at the end of the day we're
going to get some kind of exponential
concentration in the number of buckets
then within each bucket we will compute
some kind of naive estimator of the
thing we want to estimate so in this
case
it's just going to be the empirical
covariance but if you were doing
regression you might compute an ordinary
least squares estimator
uh if you're doing measuring the mean
you might compute uh compute
the the empirical mean within each
bucket you compute some some naive
estimator
then the second step is is kind of the
non-trivial step
what you want to do is identify some
some notion of quantiles among
these um these independent estimators
that you
that you have available to you of what
you wanted to estimate so these in this
case i'm going to call them z1
through z log 1 over delta which are my
independent estimates of
the covariance based on averaging the
covariance within these within buckets
you want to find some notion of a
quantile here and then you want to
output some kind of point which is good
with respect to your definition of
quantiles good meaning
close to uh close to kind of quantiles
in the bulk of your distribution
so in this case we're going to make the
following key definition
which is going to be the the main the
main definition for the second half of
the talk
i'm going to define uh something called
a spectral r
center of the set of matrices z1 to z
log 1 over delta
so we will call another matrix m a
spectral r
center r is some real number if for
every unit vector v
the distance between the quadratic forms
of the matrix zi and the matrix m
at the vector v is at most r
and this holds for let's say 60 of the z
i's
so um this is a definition worth
absorbing for a little bit notice that
it is
weaker than saying that um
that zi has spectral norm distance
less than r to m
why is it weaker than this well the
reason is that
which 60 of the zi's you um
m is close to could depend on what
direction i
am looking in okay so as i as i move
this vector v around i will be close to
a difference
m will be close to a different set of
zi's but it will always be close to at
least 60 percent of them
if i look in directions that look like
vv transpose
so this spectral r center notion this is
some notion of a
of a quantile in high dimension like a
60
quantile
the key
the key steps to designing an estimator
if we don't worry about running time
for a second are the following two facts
which are proved
um by lugosi and mendelssohn and
mendelssohn and jivatovsky
so they proved two two things the first
is
where all of the non-trivial probability
work happens this is kind of a
remarkable
statement it turns out that
with high probability with probability
one minus delta over all of the
underlying x's
um the the empiric the true covariance
excuse me the population covariance
is a spectral center of these bucketed
covariance matrices
for exactly the right value of r
actually with a
maybe i'm missing a logarithmic factor
here but almost exactly the right value
of of r this is a this is a
quite non-trivial statement about
concentration right to establish this
kind of
this kind of property for the
population covariance matrix sigma
second fact which is much easier to
prove is that if you have
two spectral r centers m and m prime
then
they actually have to be close in
operator norm so if any two spectral r
centers
are at most distance two r in operator
norm
and together these two facts mean that
in order
to compute a good estimator right all
you have to do
is find a spectral r center so it's easy
to implement the first step of this
median of means paradigm you take your
samples you put them in buckets you
compute empirical covariances
um and for the second step we just need
to uh
to find us to find a spectral our center
of the bucketed covariances
so i'm going to describe the sort of uh
outer algorithm and appeal to an
an oracle which is really doing most of
the work and then i'll describe
the main innovation that we make which
is how to implement and analyze this
oracle
so our algorithm will compute a spectral
r center we will not manage to do it for
the optimal value of r as i've said we
will manage to do it only for some
larger value of r larger by a log one
over delta to the one quarter factor
our strategy algorithmically is to
compute a series of iterates
so some d by d matrices m1 m2 m3 and so
on until we
reach some final estimator m the first
matrix will just be some naive estimate
of the of the covariance you could just
use the empirical covariance if you want
um at each step we're going to try to
get closer
to the population covariance and the way
that we'll do it
is at each step we will try to check
whether or not what we have
already is a spectral r center
if it is great we're done we'll output
it if it's not
we hope that our algorithm to check
whether it's a special r center
if it fails it will tell us some
direction in which our current
our current matrix m i is not well
approximating the quadratic forms of
many of the z's
many of the bucketed covariances if i'm
told the direction where mi
is failing to correctly approximate the
quadratic forms of the z's
i can update m i to m i plus 1
and i should be i should get closer to
to correctly approximating the quadratic
forms of the zs
so there's some simple kind of gradient
descent potential function argument that
shows that is that these kind of updates
will make progress
if i have an oracle which when which
given an mi that is not a spectral r
center
finds me um a bad direction a direction
where
i'm not getting in the quadratic form
right
so that that kind of argument was
pioneered in this um
in this setting in this paper by um
yeshwanth
nick flammarian and peter bartlett from
last year and we basically adapted to
the covariance matrix setting but it's
not
nothing super new is going on the meat
is
where is how to implement this oracle
how do you check
whether or not a matrix that i give you
is a spectral r center
so for the rest of the talk i'm going to
talk about this question if i
give you let's say that i even give you
there's two ways to think of this
question the first way is if i give you
an arbitrary matrix and i give you z1 to
z log 1 over delta
can you decide whether or not that
matrix is a spectral r center
a different way to think of the question
is in terms of what tcs people would
call certification
if i can can you design an algorithm
which
given any matrix which is not a spectral
r center
always returns no and given some
particular matrix that is a specular
center like let's say
the population covariance with high
probability the algorithm returns yes
so therefore that algorithm is that
certifies
that indeed this um the matrix that you
gave it is a spectral r center that or
the rather that
the population covariance is a spectral
r center
so the rest of the talk will be about
this this certification problem
the algorithm that we designed for the
certification problem we will use as our
oracle
to compute updates in our event in our
outer algorithm for actually finding a
spectral our center
any questions
okay so to do this we're going to take
an optimization approach
we will turn the property of being a
spectral r center
into an optimization problem uh
whose value decides whether or not a
given matrix is a spectral our center
and then we will we will design and
solve a convex relaxation of this
optimization problem
so um let me describe how you can
transform spectral r centerness
into an optimization problem uh this
optimization problem let me actually
get to the point that has the picture
there you go
this optimization problem it is
parametrized by some given matrix
m and of course your bucketed covariance
matrices z
and what it does is search for a
direction
in which m is not approximating the
quadratic forms of
many of the z's well so how will i
formulate that
well i'm going to have some variables
that represent the direction let's call
them v
1 up to v d together they form some
vector
v and i'm going to have
some boolean variables which are
indicators for whether or not
so there'll be log one over delta
boolean variables remember log one over
delta because that's the number of
z's that there are and when i set the
i one of these boolean variables to 1
think of it as an indicator
that in direction v
m is poorly approximating z so i'm going
to try to maximize
over directions the number of bad
matrices
z and i need to capture that the bis
really mean
bad matrices so that i'll do with this
this is the
important constraint here um
if vi is set to zero then this
constraint reads zero greater than equal
to zero and it's a no op
but if bi equals one it turns on this
constraint
and when this constraint is turned on
what it says is that
the quadratic form of z in direction v
is much bigger than the quadratic form
of m
in direction v okay there's a little bit
of a sine issue one has to deal with the
fact that here i wanted absolute values
but this
turns out to not be a big problem so i'm
going to sweep it under the rug
more or less up to that sine issue this
optimization problem captures spectral r
center-ness if the optimum value is at
most
let's say 0.6 log 1 over delta
then in every direction m correctly
approximates 60
of the zi's quadratic forms whereas if
the optimum value is bigger there is
some bad direction
so we know that if i
replace m by by sigma by the true
population covariance
you know we know that the true
population covariance is a spectral our
center
even for this optimum value of r so we
know that
if i look at this at this optimization
problem that
with high probability probability 1
minus delta
its optimum value is at most 0.6 log 1
over delta
right but our goal is we're not going to
be able to solve this optimization
problem exactly
inside our algorithm it's it's
non-convex you know it's
got these boolean variables it's got
degree three polynomials in the
variables showing up
and so instead we're going to have to
design some kind of convex relaxation
of this uh of this program
our goal will be to design a convex
relaxation which maintains this property
maintains this property of the of the
of the program the only way we're going
to be able to do it is if we slack in
our value of r
somewhat so it's maybe not obvious by
this point in the talk but
as you make r bigger it becomes easier
to prove upper bounds on
on this problem on this program so our
goal will be to design
a convex relaxation for r not too much
larger than this
optimal r such that the optimum value of
this problem is
of the convex relaxation is still 0.6
log 1 over delta
that optimum value will certify an upper
bound we'll start we'll certify that
when i replace m with the true
population covariance sigma
that it will certify that sigma
is indeed a spectral r center
okay so in my last 10 minutes or so
um i want to describe how we designed
this convex program
and how we analyze it so now i get to
tell you about these
these i think kind of cool techniques
that bring
fairly classic concentration of measure
tools to bear to analyze
the optimum of this sort of thorny
looking convex program
okay so as i said i have
i have this non-convex problem
and you can at this point you can
basically forget most of the rest of the
talk
you have this non-convex problem it's
parametrized by these random matrices zi
that come from some heavy tail
distribution
and some matrix m that i'm trying to
certify whether or not it's a
it's a spectral r center
um actually you should think of m here
as being
you should really think of it as being
like
expectation of z i
uh we want to design a convex relaxation
of this
that will
maintain the property that it's small
its value is small with high probability
right probability 1 minus delta so i
need exponential concentration
in the number of zi's so my first claim
is that i don't really have to worry so
much about concentration
that actually it's going to be enough to
talk about the expected optimum value
and the reason is that i claim any
reasonable convex relaxation
of this problem of this of this
optimization problem is going to satisfy
a bounded difference inequality
so first let's see why does the optimum
value concentrate before i worry about
convex relaxation well
i claim that the optimum value here
satisfies a bounded difference in
equality of the following form
if i take any set of vectors any set of
matrices z 1 to z log 1 over delta
and i denote by opt the optimum value
here when i put in z
1 to z log 1 over delta i claim the
optimum value can change by at most one
if i swap out some zi for some other
matrix zi prime
don't have to worry about what
distribution the matrices come from just
i take an arbitrary set of z1 to z log 1
over delta and i swap one of them out i
change one coordinate
if i can establish this then you know
classic concentration of measure tells
me that this
this function opt of z1 to z-log 1 over
delta will concentrate exponentially
well
around its mean as long as the z's are
independent random variables which they
are in this case
so why why would this be the case why do
i get a bounded differences
inequality here well imagine what
happens
if i take a feasible solution to this
problem
for z for like the set of matrices z1 to
z log 1 over delta so a feasible
solution
you know drawing over here the z's live
like this here's my z's z1
z2 z3 and a feasible solution
here's m a feasible solution is some
vector v
such that uh
you know opt many of the z's
are within distance r to m or a farther
from the distance r from m
right and now the point is that if i
swap out one of the z's for some
other matrix z prime
it can only change by one the number of
z's which
are within distance r to m
so the optimum value can change by at
most one
so that's why the non-convex problem
satisfies bounded differences
now why do i say that any reasonable
convex relaxation would have to satisfy
bounded differences
well i didn't use very many properties
of of the
of the of this non-convex problem
right what did i use well surely my
convex relaxation whatever it turns out
to be it will have some proxy variables
let's call them capital bi
for these boolean variables little bi
and you know surely it will have a
constraint like the bis have to live
between zero and one
because my little bis were meant to be
boolean variables
and also i would hope although this is
this is a little bit less obvious
that whatever convex relaxation i arrive
at it will be possible to take a
feasible solution
and perform the operation of setting
one of the bis to zero that's like
deactivating this constraint
at which point i can swap out the matrix
zi for any other matrix z i prime and
maintain feasibility
right so those properties being able to
set one of the bis to zero and
deactivate
a constraint and the fact that the bi
that i set to zero can't have been
contributing very much to my objective
function because it's bounded by
one as long as my convex relaxation has
those properties it will satisfy bounded
differences
and therefore its optimum value you know
we could call it like
relaxed opt will satisfy
uh what will will concentrate
exponentially around its mean
so what that means is that even though
my goal was to show that the optimum
value of this
of this problem is small with high
probability with probability one minus
delta
actually it's enough to understand the
expected optimum value
um and you know going from high
probability to expectation
in the setting that i have uh my
underlying random variables are
heavy-tailed
this could make my life significantly
easier right i just bought myself the
kind of concentration that i was really
worried about
when i said that the zi's might be
heavy-tailed and therefore there might
be
nasty outliers so the last thing we have
to do
is understand the expected optimum of
this
of this program expected over the random
matrices z1 to z log 1 over delta
and we need to do it we're going to do
it only with an assumption
you know this this eighth moment
assumption on the underlying random
matrix
a random vector x so remember that the
zi is you know under the hood
these are the average of some some
samples
like from the i bucket of samples these
are the empirical covariance within each
bucket
so i have some kind of moment control on
a constant number of moments of these
x's
and i want to use that moment control to
understand the expected optimum
here
so now of course i have to tell you what
the actual convex relaxation is that
we're going to use
in uh because i'm going to have to i'm
going to have to exploit more properties
of it than i did before to get a bound
on the expected opt
we use this thing called a sum of
squares semi-definite program
the sum of squares hierarchy is a tool
that offers
a convex relaxation or actually a family
of increasingly strong convex
relaxations
for any polynomial optimization problem
a polynomial optimization problem is the
problem of maximizing or minimizing
some polynomial in some unknowns subject
to constraints on those unknowns which
are themselves
expressed as polynomial inequalities so
let's very briefly see why our problem
is actually a polynomial optimization
problem
our objective function is a polynomial
in the variables b
that's good we can very easily make
these first two constraints polynomials
we can just ask the square of the
euclidean norm of v is one the square
euclidean norm is a polynomial in v
and we can ask that v i times one minus
v
i is zero that's a constraint that's a
polynomial constraint on the b's that
enforces that they live in in 0 1
and then this last constraint is an
inequality of polynomials in the b's
and the v's so we have a polynomial
optimization problem
the sum of squares stp will have proxy
variables
for all of the low degree monomials
in these underlying variables b and v so
as i said before there will be some
proxy variable i called it before
capital bi
for um for little bi but there will also
be a proxy variable for the product of
two variables bibj
and a proxy for say you know the degree
three monomials that are appearing
in this expression and so um on
i i don't really have time to give you
the whole semi-definite program i'm
going to tell you a couple of key
properties of it that we use to analyze
the expected
the expected optimum
and then i will wrap up so
uh the first the first thing that i'm
going to claim
so i need i need to analyze the expected
opt of this thing which you've now seen
a million times
i'm going to claim that the sdp that i
design
it sort of supports analogs of the
following operations that i could do to
bound the optimum value of the
non-convex variant
the first step is i need to use these
constraints right i've got these
constraints that tell me why
you know what what does it mean that
i've turned on one of the bis what does
it mean for bi to be 1
well for bi 2b1 it means that this this
thing is large
and so i can upper bound to the number
of bis that are 1
by this expression right maximize over b
and v
1 on r by moving this r over here sum of
b
i times the difference in quadratic
forms of
z and its expectation and then i can do
koshi schwartz
on on this sum and i can separate out
the b's
and these moments in of the v's
sorry moments of these of these z
matrices
uh and i can upper bound this thing by
the maximum over all unit vectors
of some some constant not depending on v
not depending on um on the x's
times this degree two polynomial
in these z matrices okay so i just did
koshi schwartz on here
and then i collapsed this inner product
notation to make things compact
i did these operations in the land of
the non-convex optimization problem so
you have to believe me that whatever
convex
program i'm going to design supports
these operations
but at the end of the day what we will
get out of it is that instead of
trying to bound the expected optimum of
a convex relaxation of this problem
it will be enough to bound the expected
optimum of a convex relaxation
of this problem this is the maximization
of some degree four polynomial
on the unit sphere okay so i got rid the
message is i got rid of the boolean
variables i got rid of the b
variables and now i just have to worry
about convex optimization of
convex relaxations of polynomial
optimization on the unit sphere
and for those of you who have worked
with these sum of squares sdps this is
where they really shine
so the last tool that we use is this
thing that i call the sum of squares
bernstein inequality
which is a generalization of matrix
bernstein that we prove
in our paper in order to analyze exactly
this polynomial
so notice that what i want to do is i
want to analyze some convex relaxation
of an optimization problem involving a
polynomial which is a
sum of independent random polynomials
right they're log one over delta
independent random polynomials here in
the sum they're identically distributed
so i should be able to exploit that to
understand some some kind of
concentration for this
the first thing i'm going to do is to
draw the analogy
with the matrix-bernstein inequality i'm
going to rewrite
this expression you know my convex
relaxation
will of course take we'll take the
following form it will be the maximum
of over some d squared by d
squared matrices d squared by d squared
because
i have here some degree 4 polynomial in
the vectors v
that live in some special cone
some stp called the sum of squares stp
the maximum of those matrices inner
product with the sum
over i of these independent identically
distributed random matrices
so this is a little bit quick i
understand that it's maybe not obvious
without doing the algebra why these are
the same thing
but i promise that they are and you can
see now the analogy
to the to the spectral norm and the
matrix bernstein inequality
because if instead of y in sos i had
just
traced y equals one
you know ypsd then i would be writing
here the spectral norm
of of this sum of independent random
matrices
so we could think of writing this as a
norm this is we want to know the
expected
sos norm where the sos norm is whatever
is induced by this sdp
of this sum of independent random
matrices
and the point of the sos bernstein
inequality that we prove
is that it allows us to control the sos
norm of this sum of independent matrices
by the sos norm of its expected square
so matrix bernstein lets you control the
spectral norm of a sum of independent
matrices
by a variance term which is the spectral
norm of
the expected squares of those matrices
and we can generalize this to a more
interesting family of norms these
sum of squares norms um
i'm hi i'm sweeping many things under
the rug which you're
free to try to call me on in uh in the
in the question
question section but the last thing i
want to note to tie this together
is that i can finally tell you why i
needed this degree eight
certifiable hyper contractivity it is
and i understand that it's not you're
just gonna have to take my word for it
it is exactly the thing which allows you
to control the sos
norm of the expected squares of these
matrices
you can maybe at least pattern match a
little bit about
why that could be the case these
z's are degree two functions of the
underlying samples
x and so this whole thing is a degree
eight function
of the underlying samples x and the
certifiable hyper-contractivity
can be re-expressed as a bound on the
sos norm of the eighth moment
of uh of the underlying random vector
okay so just wrapping up um
thanks for bearing with me on some on
some technical slides
uh this all this
all this business that i'm talking about
yields a heavy tailed covariance
estimation algorithm with this
slightly sub-optimal guarantee the
multiple by log
one over delta to the one-quarter um
here are some
open problems in this area one would be
of course remove this log one over delta
to the one quarter algorithmically i
think there actually are roadblocks to
this
i have a talk online i'm happy to talk
to you afterwards about what those
roadblocks look like
um covariance estimation and linear
regression are closely related and so
there's a there's a
an analogous question almost exactly
analogous to
um giving an optimal algorithm for
heavy-tailed linear regression
and then for finally i think there
should be more applications of these two
techniques i illustrated in the second
part of the talk
the bounded difference inequality
applied to these kind of counting convex
programs these
complex programs for um
for high-dimensional quantiles and this
sos bernstein inequality
okay um thanks for your attention for
making it through to the end of the day
i'm happy to take questions
all right yeah thanks for a great talk
you went over a lot of stuff
uh are there questions
it's like maybe thomas it was a little
more action-packed than i expected
yeah thanks for the talk um i was
wondering is it is it obvious
that if the distribution is not too aids
certifiable hyper contractive
do you have a distribution whether the
scp is bad with high probability
it's always nasty to cook up like
something that
that's even even even cooking up
distributions that are not certifiably
to a type or contractive uh
is very hard i i maybe i'm being
maybe i'm forgetting something but like
i actually think i only know one
construction here and it's really
it's nasty it's like uh
the reason it would be hard is comes
from small set expansion you use
somehow the the the distribution over
vectors
from the top eigenspace of us of a graph
um and that has to be hard otherwise if
you could if you could certify it you
would certify small set expansion
but i actually i know very few
constructions maybe that's the only one
of a distribution that i am pretty
convinced is not certifiably
hyper-contractive so the short answer
question is no
i don't know such a such an example
uh now i'm just having trouble swapping
back in what's what's going on here
so uh
what you described is a is only is a
conjectural right well you described as
a conditional
sdp uh integrality yeah yeah yeah i just
have reason to believe it's not
certifiably hyper-contractive i don't i
can't even i can't prove it
unconditionally
i mean in other words uh 2-8 hyper
conductivity
for all we know is is uh
not not only efficiently satisfiable it
could be sos certifiable
it could be i think so maybe somebody
else on this calls
on this call remembers better but i
think
it could be sos certifiable
i mean we know we know integrality gaps
for general
um you know degree eight polynomial
optimization
right but the point is that that the
family of polynomials that you're trying
to optimize for
sort of for certifiable hyper
contractivity they have this very
special form
right you have a random vector
a random a random vector inner product
with uh your unknowns v
and then averaged over and the
integrality gaps we know don't look like
that
you know we know like random polynomials
or something
it's a nice open problem to hook up um
some integrality gaps
uh quick clarification on stars's result
was this was also algorithmic
yes his result is algorithmic yeah
actually you can
you can do his um
by you still do this median of means
trick um
like you put put your samples in buckets
but then you can com
you can use some more naive way to
aggregate the buckets
so in particular i think i don't swear
to it
but i think that if you just output you
know you you look for the smallest ball
that contains like 60
of the bucketed guys and then
output the center of that ball where the
but it's a spectral norm a spectral
normal ball
um i think you will
get his guarantee so you can do
something more naive at the aggregation
step
and uh your o tildes are
polylux and d or n or
that is a question i wish i remembered
the answer to
they're definitely polylogs in d i think
they are only poly logs in d
but uh let me send you an email to
confirm that
no it's okay just curious thank you yeah
okay so yeah thanks again to all the
speakers today thanks sam
there is maybe someone has the link
the the omid sent around the gather town
link
earlier today if people want to go there
to chat
but i don't have it any longer so
well well nobody's gonna make it there
to chat if uh is it in an email
no no other people may have the link
still i just lost the link
i see maybe somebody could put it in the
chat that's what i'm hoping
so if anyone has it put it please put it
in the chat and they'll meet if you're
still around
just uh please put it in my channel i'm
here i'm i'm going to put it in there
right now oh jesse
there we go got it okay so there's a
gathered town
in the chat if people want to keep
talking
yeah thanks again see everyone tomorrow
thanks everyone bye
you